les acteurs de la mission d'information
sur le suivi de la fermeture de la
centrale nucléaire de fessenheim se sont
réunis ce jeudi à paris edf doit
conserver la maîtrise de la sûreté du
site de fessenheim a déclaré le
directeur général de l'institut de
radioprotection et de sûreté nucléaire
jean christophe niel ce jeudi pour
l'heure seul le premier des deux
réacteurs de fessenheim a été débranché
le réacteur numéro deux doit suivre le
30 juin elle les combustibles usés
seront évacués d'ici l'été 2023 le
démantèlement complet de la centrale ne
devrait être achevé qu'en 2040
à la sortie de la réunion ce matin les
acteurs de la mission d'information
parlementaire semblait mitigé sur
l'issue de cette audition et sur
l'avenir du site écoutez nous a donné
des informations sur le démantèlement
sur le calendrier sur le protocole chez
l'impact
donc c'était attendu maintenant on
l'avait dit dans le programme
nous l'avons fait et c'est ta route
déchets seront traités à la hague qui
est une usine et qu'il conçut pour cela
et ensuite le stockage se fera dans des
mines qui sont prévues à cet effet
souterraine ensuite
pour ce qui est de démolition on va dire
des installations il ya un programme
aussi est en place on a beaucoup
beaucoup d'attentes qui est son dernier
rôle à tort ou que j'entends sur ce
qu'on va faire sur ce territoire comment
on va organiser la position économique
et énergétique de ce territoire
et puis aussi comment ça se passait pour
démantèlement parce que là on a vraiment
laboratoires absolument extraordinaire
qui va semer trop